CBS News chief legal correspondent Jen
Crawford joins us now from Washington
she's reported on most of the major
judicial appointments and confirmation
hearings for the last 25 years
Jen good morning what struck you in the
television appearance last night from
Brett Kavanaugh well I mean I think the
clip that we just saw there where he
really kind of went out of his way to
avoid attacking her while repeatedly
saying you know I did not do this but I
thought throughout the the interview he
kind of smoked almost in like measured
tones like he was trying to stay in
control of his emotions a little bit so
you didn't see as much emotion or anger
as I thought you might have expected
there was one time I thought or at least
twice where he almost broke down when he
started talking about the kind of high
school students that he thought he
thought that he had been that he had
tried to be the number one in his class
captained the basketball team and he
almost kind of lost it at that moment I
think it'll be really interesting on
this hearing to see how his demeanor
might be different remember Justice
Thomas when he testified those many
years ago was it was angry and really
lashed out of the senators picking up on
that description of him in high school
you heard senator Amy Klobuchar say that
that she wanted to ask him about whether
his description of how he behaved in
high school matches with the way he
actually behaved saying that goes to his
credibility do you think we're gonna be
basically back in the 1980s talking
about behavior and a lot of this hearing
you know John one of the main takeaways
from the Clarence Thomas Anita Hill
hearings is that everybody said that
should never happen again so I think
it's been interesting to see some of
this stuff kind of very similar to the
situation that we're now and you're
going to hear a lot about high school in
this one I mean at least that one was in
the workplace those allegations you know
you're gonna hear a lot about who did
what drinking this was obviously a
different time so you've got to put it
in the context of you know the late 80s
when 18 was the drinking age college
seniors may be able to let differently
than they do today with the drinking age
21 you know it's you yeah I mean it's
gonna be a lot about high school and
clubs and what people said and who that
may or may not have dated who knew what
how unusual is it to see a Supreme Court
nominee give an interview like this and
what was the thinking on their team
about why he needed to do it well I mean
it's like it's never happened before I
think that anyone can remember but I
I think these are highly unusual times
and you could say that some of these
kind of situations have never happened
before - I mean remember with Hill and
Thomas and I was covering some of that
back then - believe it or not one of the
big differences is when Anita Hill came
for it and her allegations became public
the hearing happened in a much closer
timeframe so Justice Thomas was able to
go out and give his side of the story
before the Senate Judiciary Committee
within a matter of days here judge
Cavanaugh has been really kind of
hanging out there for a long time and so
and there's been a much longer period
from when these allegations first
started getting rumored and when they
came forward so people close to him
thought you've got to come forward and
give your side of the story you can't
hang out there anymore
it's really interesting Jan thank you
very much